use again our regular look at America by
the numbers when we take a look at
statistics and help you kind of
understand them especially to where you
live and where your how your wallet is
affected this week two guests joining us
the first Brent molted he's with the
Bureau of Economic Analysis he's the
National Economic accounts associate
director also joining us for this
discussion Neil Irwin of the Washington
Post and serves as their economic
columnist to both of you gentlemen
welcome mr. Moulton let's start with you
in the papers today there is a line
about personal incomes and it says that
the Commerce Department reported
personal incomes rose 2.6 percent in
December from the month before and it
was a revised the number upward for
November can you little give a little
bit of detail about this report and what
it's about sure we put out a personal
income report every month in December we
did have a larger than usual increase
and there were some special factors
going on then in particular a number of
companies paid out dividends in
anticipation of tax law changes also
some some companies paid out special
bonuses so that did lead to an unusually
strong number for December but you know
the in general we you know this this it
was a temporary kind of thing so we
would not expect those kinds of 2.6 for
December how about overall how did the
year look I'm yeah for the for the year
overall we had an increase of 3.5% for
for the year 2012 and so you know that's
that's a good increase but you know it
it's a little below the long-term trends
as well and is that just when you say
personal income is that take-home pay or
is that are several factors that are
associated with that yeah there there
are a number of factors involved in
personal income we with in personal
income we have wages and salaries which
are account for more than half of the
total but we also have small business
income
things like rental income and also
investment income in terms of interest
and dividends and so forth and then
there's transfer income Social Security
benefits unemployment insurance benefits
and and so forth that so so there's a
variety of types of income that are it's
an all-encompassing kind of measure of
household in so Neil Irwin a little bit
of boosts as far as money is concerned
what does it say overall at least not
only from how people personally did but
overall it doesn't speak to the economy
overall yeah what we're seeing is an
economy that is that is slowly gradually
recovering from from the crisis and
recession of 2008-2009 you know the the
similar number we can put aside for a
minute because that's very heavily as as
we heard about investment income and
companies paying dividends ahead of tax
tax increases but even over the longer
time horizon
we are seeing incomes rise we are seeing
people are earning more money companies
are starting to put people back to work
job growth is happening we just got a
report this morning on job creation in
in January so certainly this is not a
happy days are here again everything's
fine everything's you know this is not
an economy that's fully healed but it is
making gradual steady progress in that
direction and again it takes a look at a
lot of factors at least from the Bureau
of Economic Analysis report you look at
wages you look at income you look at
rental incomes you look at investment
incomes as a whole and that kind of
paints a picture of where Americans
stand financially that's right you know
ultimately you know you can't buy the
things you need if you don't have income
coming from somewhere and for some
people that's overwhelmingly a paycheck
from their job for retirees might be
Social Security benefits pension
benefits for for for people who've
invested a lot and saved over the years
it might be investment income dividends
interest payments from from their
investments but wherever it comes from
that's the that's the core of your
capacity to buy the things you need and
want our guests are going to be joining
us to take a look at these numbers and
take a look at your personal income and
how it's doing here's how we've divided
the lines today if you want to join in
the conversation if economically
financially if you will if you're doing
better give us a call at this number 202
five eight five three eight eight zero
if you do
- OH - five eight five three eight eight
one and if you are rating it about the
same - OH - five eight five three eight
a - you can send us a tweet - kind of
reflecting those categories if you want
at c-span WJ you can also send us an
email at journal at c-span org mr.
Moulton look a graphic that says what
happens to household incomes it shows an
uprising chart it shows an annual
percent change I think we've talked
about these but when you take a look at
the percent change in 2011 its 5.1
percent if you take a look at 2012 its
3.5% tell us what happened in between um
well there was a bit of a slowdown in in
2012 compared to 2011 now in 20 2011 we
did have some some boost from in
particular the payroll tax cut and some
of the other kinds of things but still
we are seeing steady growth this is the
third consecutive year that personal
income has grown so you can see that
earlier dropped during 2008 and 2009
right was during the recession so we are
getting growth but you can see we're
still below the trend that we were on
before the recession it's go ahead so I
you know I think relative to the sort of
typical increase that we had before the
recession which averaged between five to
five and a half percent a year that were
still well below that trend you and what
would you add so as far as these numbers
are concerned yeah that's that's right
what what happened is the economy was
humming along in the mid 2000s end of
2007 Oh 809 hit a big bump and and
really dropped and we've been the kind
of expanding in both personal incomes
and other measures of economic
performance been growing and expanding
since the middle of 2009 however it's it
hasn't been growing fast enough to make
up that lost ground it's been growing at
about the same pace it did historically
so as if it was going up to shift down
and then got on the same on the same old
path
other than accelerating and catching up
we haven't had a catch-up effect of
making up the lost economic ground and
that's why you still have 8%
unemployment that's why you still have
people feel like they're they're not
earning as what they would like because
we haven't had that catch-up effect
happen and mr. Moulton referred to the
payroll tax cut which saw an increase at
the end of last year into this year does
that affect how future numbers as far as
this line is concerned in your opinion
that will affect disposable personal
income so after-tax income the the
course the payroll taxes is what pays
for Social Security at the end of 2010
it was cut by two percentage points as a
stimulus measure to give Americans a
little more money in their pocket it's 2
percent of worker pay for most workers
that was allowed to expire the end of
December so that first paycheck in
January for basically all Americans was
was something like 2% higher than it or
lower rather than it would have been in
December that's less take-home pay less
after-tax income that's less money you
have to spend and we'll probably see
that on the consumption side as we get
into 2013 store multiple ad me
summarized it very well as far as
statistic how do you compile this
information what information do you take
to make these charts and graphs happen
well we these are part of the National
Accounts which really are designed to
cover the entire economy and we have
within that a household sector corporate
sector and so forth we're drawing data
from really hundreds of different
sources to put this again together we
have administrative records for four
payrolls as well as surveys so we're
really bringing together a lot of
different data sources to put these
numbers together here's our first call
Rockville Maryland category for doing
better then is on the line been first
and foremost tell us why you're doing
better well I got a new job about six
weeks ago after entering a new field for
about two years and so I kind of did my
apprenticeship and got my uh my
background and then I was able to land a
better job and what's uh what field do
you work in all proper commercial
property management personal property so
go ahead with your question comments are
all well it just seems like um in a few
years my previous job a lot of the
action that was happening in making
these um making the economy recovers all
happening at the community bank level
with the community banks that get the
value of the local business whereas the
larger banks want the national ones that
want the national tenants it's the
community banks that look at a person as
a whole and say well yes property a is
not doing great but property b's doing
excellent if we can pick up two that's
fine
it's the community banks that had
developed that relationship that helped
rebuild things from the ground up I and
I just did not see it at the national
bank level and why are we putting more
money into the community banks I don't
understand it you are why you take that
one yeah you know it's interesting point
I think we've seen a lot of this in the
economy that a lot of the smaller banks
all over the country now there were in
2009-2010 quite a few of those smaller
banks that failed and went under but
those that are left are generally pretty
strong they have they have capital they
have depositors they you know people who
maybe didn't want to deposit their money
at at one of the the mega banks said you
know I'm going to go to my Main Street
Bank down the street and put my money
there and as the caller says they tend
to have a good understanding of local
markets of local real estate conditions
and situations what what sort of demand
is out there for different kinds of
properties so they can make loans on
projects that maybe a JP Morgan or a
city bank wouldn't even take a look at
it's interesting area of strength of the
economy I think it is an area where
where the US banking system has been
surprisingly resilient partly because we
have institutions of all sizes with all
kinds of different priorities in Europe
for example it's more dominated by these
very large mega banks that are that are
that are enormous and so maybe a source
of strength for the American economy is
also having smaller institutions that
are close to the ground level Garden
City New York doing the same this is
Rosalee hello I'm hi how are you thank
you for taking my call I had a question
I'd like to look at or actually if your
guest can talk about at a more granular
level yes personal income has increased
however can you break it down to how
much of that increase came from interest
income stocks etc versus people who are
just middle to lower middle class who
would just basically get their personal
income from their wages and their
salaries
well mr. Mohn you have a chart here
taking a look at
investment income the title says how
important his investment income and
talks about personal income receipts
when it takes a letter assets what is
this chart telling us okay the
investment income chart does look
specifically at interest and dividend
income as you know interest rates are
still quite low so in interest income is
pretty low dividend income has been
improving as corporates profits have
have returned and so forth but if you
look at the chart you can see we're
still quite a bit below the level that
we were at before the recessions and the
there was an increase in 2012 of 3.8
percent so it accounted for some of the
increase in personal income but not all
of it and reflective of some of the
other charts the increase in 2011 was
five point four percent that's right yes
so it's it's again decelerating from
from the increase we had the prior year
no irwin how much our investments a part
of a personal portfolio these days
stocks bonds 401ks that the like it
depends on the person I mean there's
obviously people and families for whom
investment income is the overwhelming
source of their of their income and
wealth there are others who are
scratching by you don't really have a
lot of savings in the bank or in stock
or bond investments who were living
paycheck to paycheck but this is one of
the areas where where the distribution
of where people get their income is is
you know most disbursed and there's the
most variation and how different
households have where they make their
money and how they use it
stone fort Illinois doing worse is the
category this is Jay Jay go ahead yes
it's been harder on us we're in that
category of making under $250,000 a year
and Illinois increased our employment
taxes 66 percent I believe it was it
took over a hundred and ten dollars a
month out of my paycheck and then just
recently this new tax took another
hundred and ten dollars of the amount of
money I have to spend out there is just
decreasing and I'm I'm my wife now we
have invited increasingly gift
even saving money um we seem to be
drowning uh thanks very much taking my
call uh Laura from Twitter says I got a
raise but my take-home is less because
of that increase in taxes and health
insurance premiums so she sums it up by
saying I went backward mr. Moulton the
there's chart here taking a look at
income after taxes tell us more yes
taxes both taxes and inflation certainly
nibble away at the purchasing power of
households so the chart we showed
earlier was not adjusted for inflation
or taxes but we do have a measure called
real disposable income that does adjust
for that and that increased 1.5 percent
in 2012 you can see that's quite a bit
less than then we saw in personal income
and that compared to 1.3 percent in 2011
the other factor I'd point out is that
it's only four point three percent above
where it was in 2007 before the
recession and even that four point seven
percent is mostly coming from population
growth so if you look at per capita real
disposable income it's essentially
unchanged so that basically says that
the typical American family really
hasn't seen any improvement since 2007
new Urwin what what Chad yeah we see
that another and other measures of wages
and and how Americans are doing as well
there's been a tough environment we've
you know we've seen wage gains but only
in nominal terms and in real terms
inflation adjusted basically flat
depending on you know a little a little
positive or a little negative depending
on on where exactly the numbers settle
in any given year but but we're really
not seeing any any strong upward trend
in real wages inflation adjusted
after-tax wages this increase in the
payroll tax that happened in January
we'll we'll we'll further that that
trend you know if you're if you your pay
drops two percent at a time there's two
percent inflation and you don't get a
raise you won't get a nominal raise then
that's actually getting a pay cut in
real terms and that's that's very tough
situation will there be other tax
increases to look out for not only aside
from the payroll tax cut
well the caller mentioned things at the
state level and a number of states
they've tried to balance their budgets
have looked to do that in part
on the tax side by increasing taxes you
know at the federal level this is one of
the great debates in Washington and and
will there be any further tax increases
nothing seems to be right on the agenda
right now you know the fiscal cliff deal
at the end of December seem to lock in
some tax rates and policies that could
be the log land for some time but we
have these series of negotiations and
series of cliffs next is the sequester
over over budget cuts that isn't about
taxes but it could become about taxes if
that's what is on the table in
negotiation so we seem to have no no new
federal tax increases on the horizon but
you never exactly know how things are
gonna shake out as Washington knows it's
work Brian is from Orion New York he
says he's doing better and worse Brian
tell us why ok well the question
actually thank you for taking my call by
the way the question actually reads how
are Americans doing financially so I'm
my company which is in oil repairs and
auto parts is actually don't had a
decrease in business in revenue in 2012
we had very very strong years in 29 2010
and 2011 good increases and that's
because of the fact that my industry
when people keep their cars longer and
they don't spend money on new cars we
tend to be busier so looking at myself
from 2012 we would do we had some
difficulties last year achieving the
goals that we established for sales
however it's an indication that the
economy is getting better and I found
that I've been in this business for 35
years and I found that to be quite
consistent a lot of our regular
customers that were just hanging on to
their cars piecing them together of work
all of a sudden bought new cars and if
not new at least you know one or two
year old used cars and that's a good
indication that the economy is very
slowly crawling back mr. Moulton a
category and a chart that says help
small businesses are doing why does this
fall into the category personal or
incomes well for small businesses
they're often sole proprietorships or
partnerships that that where the income
directly goes to the person who's
running the business
and we do capture unincorporated
businesses as part of personal income we
can see in the chart that that there has
been some improvement and as the caller
noted the pickup was stronger in 2010
and 2011 than it was in in 2012 we have
a 4.0 percent increase in 2012 compared
with 4.9 percent in 2011 I'll also note
that within this category there are a
wide variety of businesses so he
mentioned car repair there's also
construction real estate brokers doctors
and dentists and a variety of
professionals so it's really quite a
diverse group of people working in small
business yo are we the role of how the
small businessman doing these days it
depends on the industry quite a bit I
mean as I found that to be fascinating
call that you know there's some
industries that are counter-cyclical and
when there's a recession people aren't
buying new cars they hold onto their
older cars it hadn't occurred to me but
it makes sense that that would mean more
business for car repair shops that
people are driving a 10 or 15 year old
car instead of buying a new one you know
that it's it's a the truth is as as the
economy goes small business goes and you
can't have a real recovery until small
businesses are feeling it too and right
now this kind of slow growth environment
is we're not back to where we were in
2007 but we're making kind of slow
progress same story with small
businesses with large businesses with
households and consumers this is Robert
from Richmond Virginia who says he's
doing the same good morning Robert
good morning yeah I'm listening to you
as you talk about how Americans are
doing financially uh-uh
my next-door neighbor he travels
extensively the internationally and you
know he tells me about you know here
we're doing great in compared to the
rest of the world so I mean I mean we
have my problems obviously but we
compare our situations to rest of the
world as now and in the past so we
should feel good about ourselves
no it's a yeah it's interesting the
world is it's a it's a complex global
economy right now Europe is in recession
some European countries are in just a
terrible recession Spain has something
like 25% unemployment rate similar in
Greece parts of northern Europe aren't
so bad Germany is doing a little better
than that a lot better than that
actually but but you go around the world
Japan's been in a stagnant economic
situation for something like 20 years
you have emerging markets that are
growing rapidly but they're growing
rapidly from lower incomes and so the
place like China or Brazil or India yeah
they might have you know five seven nine
percent growth but that's starting at at
a much lower level of wealth and income
than we're used to in the United States
and Western Europe so we're you know -
it's a tough global economy out there
we've heard that from exporters they if
you're an expert you're a u.s. exporter
you sell a lot of stuff in Europe the
the fact that the European economy is in
really bad shape means you're selling
less stuff and and so it's definitely a
challenging international environment
here's a recap of the headlines from the
latest report on how America's
pocketbook is doing American incomes
Americans incomes including wage
interests from investments in government
payments like Social Security that rose
3.5 percent in 2012 surpassing the
income level before the 2007 2009
recession the incomes increased 1.5
percent in 2012 after factoring for
inflation paying taxes and when it comes
to spending adjusted for inflation that
increased 1.9 percent in 2012
that's the third straight annual
increase since 2007 2009 recession so
mr. mole in light of this people are
still spending these days they are we
yeah if we can bring up a chart we
actually have a chart about consumer
spending and this after adjusting for
inflation spending increased 1.9 percent
in 2012 and 2.5 percent in 2011 consumer
spending has been particularly picking
up in Motor Vehicles people are starting
to buy new cars again we also are seeing
in the real estate market that the some
pickup in new home construction which
had been stagnant for about six years
since the
the state crash back in 2006 so we
really are seeing consumers feeling like
they can spend their money again and
some quite a bit of strength which in
turn feeds into the full economy so
consumer spending is a large part of
gross domestic product and feeds into
the new era when there's a conundrum
because we hear about the current
condition of economy but when an iPhone
comes out people line up in stores to
buy it I know that's not everyone's case
but it seems like people are still
willing to to spend at least four
personal things and personal pleasures
yeah we've seen some to two competing
forces on the consumer front on the one
hand consumers their incomes or pence
we've been talking about all morning the
the way real disposable income is is is
not really rising last few years on the
other hand they also and they also have
less lending capacity so less ability to
borrow people aren't taking on as much
depth credit card standards or tighter
it's hard to get harder to get a home
mortgage so tighter credit stagnant
incomes but this great Americans ire to
buy stuff we all want we all want the
latest iPhone we all want things so you
know it's consumption is the
overwhelming driver of the economy it's
70% of GDP is what people want to buy
and and it's been hard to do that when
real disposable income has been flat and
when and when credit and wealth is lower
what about credit card use how has that
changed you know it's funny that the
patterns look people are still using
credit cards but but not in quite as
dangerous way as they were before the
recession part of that is credit card
companies are are pickier and choosier
and what kind of credit they'll extend
but also the other half of it is I think
Americans are getting smarter about how
they use debt and and we've seen
household debt levels relative the size
of the economy really have come down
quite a lot in the last four or five
years that's progress that's a sign that
we're delivering where we're getting our
finances as American households into a
more sustainable kind of position mr.
bowl and I saw you shake your head does
that capture as far as the way the
spending habits are changing as far as
Americans are concerned I don't know if
you have specific said that but that's
true
we we saw a very sharp decrease in
consumer spending during the recession
as people realize their spending was too
high relative to their level of income
but I think as in
have started to grow in the last three
years that we're finally reaching the
point where people feel that they can
you know buy those iPads or those new
cars on occasion not everyone feels that
way but many many consumers are at that
comfort level we see in the BAA data
that they put out yesterday
some real evidence of that that we have
a savings rate that's that's at a much
more sustainable level there were times
before the recession saving the personal
savings rate got down into the 2% range
that really that's that's putting
yourself in a risky position if you're a
flourish between 2007-2008 that's a
major dip as far as saving this occurred
concern right and then it skyrocketed
during the recession because what people
did is Brent says is they held onto
their wallets they didn't spend money
even those who didn't lose their jobs
those who still had an income tended to
spend less money and and that was the
result was as part of why we had a
recession but it's also about increasing
savings rate to a more sustainable level
now we're seeing levels that are in the
in the four to five percent range that
seems to be a more durable sustainable
kind of savings level and mr. Boland 4.2
percent savings rate in 2011 3.9 percent
rate in 2012 what would you add as far
as context is concerned well the context
is that you can see before the recession
we were down one to two percent is as
Neil mentioned and we did see a quite
large spike in saving just to make sure
people understand what we mean by saving
we're talking about the difference
between the total income a household
brings in and the amount they spend
during during the year so it represents
the money that's left over which they
can use to pay down their debt or to or
to save it in in terms of putting it
into the bank or or buying financial
assets and we have had higher saving
rates if you go back in history at some
periods of time we had saving rates as
high as 10% so but four to five percent
seems to be sort of the level that as
Neil mentioned has sort of been a
long-term average over the last 15-20
years and Royce from Englewood New
Jersey he says he's doing worse go ahead
Andrew hi
and afternoons first time koala um I
just wanted to add my input to this a
little bit you know I hear you guys
tossing around all these phrases and all
these words and all these terms consumer
this consumer that you know but I feel
like the answer is uh is to look at more
general things you know rather than
asking individuals their circumstances
um I think the math speaks louder than
anything else and right now um the math
is saying that with unlimited QE
spending our country has contracted
that's quite a big deal you know that's
that's 2mass factual statements right
then when you put them together you know
that should really explain to you what
is happening it's almost as this it's an
analogy to a patient having cancer and
de fueling them with chemo and still the
cancer is not color we'll leave it there
the caller gave a segue actually to a
recent headline about the economy
shrinking 0.1 percent first contraction
since 2009 put some context to it Neil
orwen yes so in the fourth quarter the
final three months of 2012 we saw a
negative 0.1 that's basically flat it's
a contraction technically but it's
basically a zero growth kind of
environment that surprise people
analysts we're expecting more like 1.1
percent still not great but at least in
positive territory this seems to been
caused almost entirely by a couple of
factors one is that businesses they
spent down their inventories they
depleted their inventories so instead of
instead of businesses making more stuff
to sell
they sold goods off of their store
shelves and out of warehouses so that so
that was one major factor the good news
is that should reverse in the in the
coming quarters businesses can't just
you know eventually run out of stuff in
the warehouse so eventually that's not
something that should be sustained the
other major factor was defense spending
took a big a big dip 22 percent annual
rate that was a surprise it it seems to
be not quite real you know there's
there's always
unevenness in how how defense spending
happens you know if the procurement
works so that a bunch of airplanes are
bought in one quarter than the other you
can have a big spike in one quarter and
a big drop the next so it's not as if
defense spending was actually cut 22
percent in the fourth quarter this seems
to be something that'll also even out
over time that said this was a reminder
that you know as we're in this era of
slow growth a weak underlying growth
combined with the fiscal tightening you
know higher taxes spending cuts we're
going to see some downward pressure on
growth coming out of out of these
efforts out of Washington to get our
budget deficit budget deficit under
control and you know hopefully we don't
have too many quarters like the forth
where it's a we end up in negative
territory but but you know this is not
an economy that's growing five six
percent and can handle those body blows
very easily where we're in a slow growth
situation Magnolia Texas David our
category for doing better hello go ahead
yeah I think this is just all stuff that
so they could hit those two security and
everything we're doing great here hey I
noticed the super bows for million
dollars a minute everything is packed
all the football stadiums all the bowl
games I don't see no depression so David
you saying you're doing better tell us
why because I I live here about 15 miles
from where they're building the number
one country in the world we get road
that's going unbelieveable around here
we got job signs everywhere and as far
as the savings when interest rates is
one and a half percent who's gonna put
their money in the bank
Bernanke wants you to put it in stock
market that's why there's no interest
rate that took my money through four
years ago when I bought them damn rifles
they're trying to do and I've already
made so much money on them it's
unbelievable David we'll leave it there
he mentioned Social Security mr. Bolten
a category and your charts about the
social safety net
can you explain sure the we use a terms
government social benefits to really
cover quite a few different provisions
for households that are provide
by the government Social Security is of
course one of the biggest but we also
include Medicare Medicaid unemployment
insurance and various other benefits
that are provided either for retirees or
for the unemployed or people needing
social assistance we see that those
payments increase quite a bit during the
recession which is what you'd expect as
as people become unemployed and collect
their unemployment insurance and so
forth that growth is really slowed down
and in 2012 it increased 2.4 percent
compared to 1.7 percent so we do expect
some growth in this overtime because we
do have the baby boom cohort Rita
entering their retirement years now so
we would expect some increase
particularly in Social Security and
Medicare as overtime but this has been
slowing down from the big increases we
saw during the recession I'll ask you
both because of the caller or the viewer
asked both of you about the affordable
health care act and if you see in a
broad sense impacting the spending in
2013 and 2014 as far as projections are
concerned the oralin uh you know it's
it's interesting it's kind of hard to
gain health care so an odd category of
spending because it for most workers
it's paid for by your employer so you
see only a small share of what it costs
for others you're actually paying money
out-of-pocket for health care so shows
up in consumption numbers for for others
it's a government benefit so it shows up
as as as government transfer payments
you know seeing how the how the
Affordable Care Act how it's going to
work and how it's going to affect all
these things I think the jury's still
out I think we there's a lot we don't
know as this thing is fully implemented
here was passed more than two years ago
and we're just seeing how this
implementation is going to work and how
it's going to affect a lot of things in
the economy mr. Moulton is this in your
purview well we only have data through
2012 and there's really been relatively
little impact so far we do expect the
numbers to show up more and as we go
into 2014 as Neil mentioned Derrick is
from haften MS Minnesota and he is doing
the same
Derek go ahead uh yeah uh can America
good mind who's been uh Brent do you
work for the you know the government or
are you independent no I I do work for
the government of the Bureau of Economic
Analysis is part of the Department of
Commerce and and we put out economic
statistics as our main business yes the
only relatives in Minnesota
calling your question please all right
my question is if it's not a question at
the comment this what we're talking
about today is how we're you know the
Americans are doing financially well
let's look at it I look at it from
50-year olds and up and and fifty year
old and below and from what I see you
know the banks are loving it because the
50 and up have been so scared with the
economy in the uncertainty that they've
kept their money in the bank which gives
the bank that leverage now the interest
rate but 0% for two years is a joke so
what we have here is we have you know
all those people who are saving or
making absolutely nothing on their money
and the devaluing of arm dollar from
what the government's doing and propping
up this economy is a detriment I mean a
fourteen year old child would get this
which I explained to my daughter last
night she understood that you don't even
go in debt you also had that interest to
it and that's the killer so you know
this whole one percent three percent
thing I'm back to that guy at New Jersey
you know the people on the ground this
is a bad economy and if you have money
you're gonna make money but the allure
one yes we have had zero interest rate
policies in place from the Federal
Reserve for for four years now and
Counting you know part of the the
rationale of why why a central bank like
the Fed does easy money policies cheap
money policies in a time of recession
and a weak economy is trying to
incentivize investment consumption it's
saying okay well if you could only get
you know a half a percent on your money
if you put it in the bank maybe you're
going to go out and build a factory with
it instead or you're maybe you're going
to go out and you know buy a car instead
it's trying to encourage consumption and
and aggregate demand in the economy that
will result in more people having jobs
and it's getting back into a
into a stronger economic place there's
no question at all that that is that's
harder for savers if you're a saver and
you want to just park your money in the
bank and and earn 5% interest with no
risk every year you know that that hurts
you if the policy succeeds in getting
the economy on track and encouraging
investment and encouraging demand then
it'll everybody will be better off but
but certainly for now if you're saver
trying to rely on on interest out of
your bank account to live on it's a very
hard environment David bridge Hampton
New York better but he says but he never
tells us why David to fill in the blanks
I would be better but the bank won't
give you the interest rates they should
automatically reset the interest rate to
the lowest rate they've offered you if
they did that me as a small business
would have more money to put back into
my business my situation I would save
over a thousand dollars a month off my
mortgage which then I could put back
into my business and then I could keep
the six employees that I have hired
employed and then maybe I could afford
to pay for health insurance for all of
them but right now the government's not
doing anything about it the banks not
doing anything about it if the banks
were forced to reset no questions asked
to the lowest interest rate that they
offered then maybe the economy would get
a really good jumpstart what interest
rates are you talking about when you're
going to the banks I'm talking about the
lowest interest rate they offered me was
uh two point nine nine but by the time I
got through doing the paperwork and
everything they lose it that whatever uh
oh you don't qualify because don't make
enough money no you don't make enough
money because you you're suffering your
business pain is high interest rates on
a mortgage that you should have the
capability of of refinancing at the
lowest rate automatically with no
questions asked and and that would
stimulate the economy what's the current
mortgage rate Mike our current mortgage
rate is uh six point seven five on a
four hundred thirty thousand dollar loan
that would that I took out six years ago
to help my business grow which was a big
joke but I'll tell you right now a
thousand dollars a month back into my
business would would help a lot
so no more question what your business
I'd I have a small retail store to strip
all and Oh in a strip mall lots more mom
pop businesses have to worry about the
big-box stores coming in and copy and
everything you do David thank you for
the input notes it's an interesting
point so this is a little bit the flip
side of what the previous caller was was
pointing out so this is one of the ways
that that the low interest rate policies
have not had as big of an effect on the
economy as I think the people over the
Federal Reserve would have hoped one of
them is that people like the caller who
have a 6.75% interest rate mortgage rate
they can only refinance into those lower
rates we have now if they are not
underwater if they have enough debt to
you know if they have a good credit
still if they have a decent debt to
equity ratio and so you know if you
can't refinance because the value of
your property is decline so you don't
have as much equity in it that's a
problem that's that's a reason that low
interest rates have not had as much of a
stimulative effect as much effect on on
demand as you'd like that said the basic
point the caller is making is the exact
counterpoint to what the previous caller
said which is that low interest rates
can help the economy so if this if this
caller was able to get the 3% interest
rate that he would like on his mortgage
he says he would have more money he
could invest in the business he could
keep his employees around that would be
good for the economy it's because of
that kind of effect is why the Fed has
these low interest rate policies in
effect which is what is also not as good
for savers who who have the flipside of
those low interest rates let's take one
more call from Naples Florida this is
Diana she says she's doing worse hello
Diana
yes I'm senior and one Medicare and
Social Security and the first thing I
wanna say real quickly I really want
talk with the interest rates but my
house is paid off and probably some half
percent average that it's paid off just
pay off going and now they do this mass
appraisal down here enables every year
and for the last I think so two hundred
and two thousand five my house is
probably at a four hundred thousand
dollar market value which was course a
little inflated but now it's down to
every year is down to 147 which is about
what I paid for 15 years ago and I wanna
move to Ohio and sell my house but I
hate to give it away that term I like to
see my husband just passed away two
years ago so I am I have money in the
bank that I'm getting not even
one percent interest on it I have an IRA
that because it's a senior you know if
you're 70 you have to you can't put
money into it you have to take some
money out every year so I'm really stuck
and people think we're all rolling in
dough down here if you're a senior but
we got this cost-of-living if you want
to call it that little and but we also
got a raise in our Medicare payment so I
just want people to know that two-color
will have to leave it there and
appreciate the input time for final
thoughts gentlemen on what you see mr.
Bolten what you want to add that we
haven't talked about already as far as
your information is concerned yeah I
think we haven't talked a lot about
wages and and wages have have gone up
some but they are still lagging behind
the rest of the economy so since the
recession there seven percent higher but
nominal GDP is up about twelve and your
we have about 15 seconds what do you
want to add but this is the economy
we're in it's it's it's growing it's not
growing as fast as most of us would like
but but it's steady progress we saw that
with the jobs report this morning
personal income data yesterday but if
you want to see the information that
we've been talking about go to our
c-span website we provided the slides
and information for you to look at we
want to thank Brent Bolton of the Bureau
of Economic Analysis and Neil Irwin of
Washington Post for this America by the
number segment gentlemen thank you